i think being in a fast-growing company
the things that keep you up is how fast
you have to solve problems
um i i think the the um
thing that keeps me up is usually a
problem has occurred at 8 pm and i now
need to solve it or generally the
company now needs to solve it before 8
a.m the next morning and as a fully
remote team and we do work across
different time zones often actually that
ends up being uh sometimes easier
because you know as you're going to
sleep someone who might be able to solve
the problem is is just waking up um and
that's definitely a benefit i think
of remote working we're definitely
advocates of remote working for sure
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
our episode today is with henry barclay
the co-founder and ceo of palo
henry spent six years growing technology
startups in the financial technology and
cyber security domains from conception
to nine-figure valuations gaining a
wealth of experience in sales ops and
product design having managed large
technology and sales teams
during this time he went through
telefonica's accelerator wayra three
investment rounds closed 40 deals with
the likes of dominoes and nike and built
b2b2c banking software in collaboration
with the tier one bank
henry was a freelancer for five years
prior to palo during this time he
advised family offices on investing into
startups and advised many seed series b
stage companies on business strategy
investment strategy product market fit
and sales operations in addition to
paolo he presently advises u.n habitat
on their city's investment facility
sitting on their investment advisory
committee and is a trust key to a uk
foundation
[Applause]
so for the last year and a half the
co-founder and ceo of palo and
looking at freelancers and looking at
the way that freelancers are managing
pretty much their their their work and
their life and you know it's it's a
it's an important question because today
we're seeing obviously an exponential
growth in freelancers the gig economy
the great resignation and the ability
for people to take ownership over what
they do when they do it and how they do
it and and so
we see an emergence of all these amazing
platforms that that are trying to figure
out what is the right way to allow
freelancers to to be at their best and
so thank you very much for joining me
and and i'd love to
hear a little bit about your your
background you know coming into this and
what sort of led to your personal
conviction around payload yeah sure so
so um i was originally in tech um and
spent a bit of time in startups
beforehand before i went freelance
myself and so i was freelance for about
uh five years um
long story cut short i'll just say i was
a consultant
um and uh four startups are helping uh
startups grow and helping family offices
and invest into startups
and
um
you know i think i found through that
journey how rewarding it is being able
to choose who you work for when to work
where to work from
um and who you work with
um you know being freelance can be an
incredibly empowering uh step in in in
someone's life um
but it comes with burdens um and myself
and two friends of mine uh now my my
co-founders um
all found that we had the same issue
which that uh as much as being freelance
can be great freelancing especially in
the states can kind of suck
um
you know there are aspects that um
sometimes put a lot of people off and
sometimes uh you know mean people uh
fail at within the first year i think
you know the burden of having to manage
it and manage your finances accounting
tax especially in the us is is very
complicated
um and um
you know it can be yeah a bit of a
burden and that's how we came to create
power as we all had the same same
problem and turns out it was a problem
for everyone
incredible so you're starting out you
understand the problem you're
experiencing yourself what
you know what what are the different
questions that you're asking yourself at
that moment yeah how do you even know
you know where where to start well i
mean at the time i was wondering why on
earth i'm paying my accountant thousands
a year plus um you know fees for
software when really my financial
situation was not that complex um
and so uh
that's that's where our our thoughts
originally lay and then um
you know we we we spoke to a a very
large number of people over a certain
nine month period um sort of covering
all sorts of different archetypes
different types of freelancer um
different demographics and so on um it
turns out they all had a sort of roughly
similar issue um which is that you know
managing your personal and business
finance accounting attacks it's
complicated costly uh costly and
disjointed so
uh you know often people don't
understand what they're doing they don't
have a very uh consistent relationship
with their finances they don't know
where they financially stand
um
they end up banking with between two to
three banking institutions which means
their money isn't all the place
um you end up you know you open one
banking app and so okay so you might
have a better understanding here but
then what about this one and the other
one
um and then ultimately you know people
see the u.s uh tax code and general
taxes is this sort of
um
horrid sort of esoteric thing that they
can't handle
and tend to then just hire an accountant
or someone uh for a large amount of
money to
to take care of that for them rather
than taking uh ownership over it which
is what a lot of freelancers become
freelance for right they want a greater
control over their work life um and
their finances and so on um and so
you know we started uh to ask uh
general freelancers whether they had the
same issues turns out they did and
and so we created palo which which
ultimately brings so all of those apps
you know the average freelancer uses
between sort of
three and five different platforms to
manage their um their finance accounting
attacks and the whole point of paulo is
it brings it into a single uh cohesive
um and succinct journey
to make life a lot easier save a lot of
time stress money
right so a lot of the theme of what
we're talking about here is this idea of
consumer behavior change and you're
mentioning how you know we can integrate
things that we've learned about
about people the workforce taxation
systems incentive systems and now change
the way we experience them but in the to
put them in the context of freelancers
in the gig economy which is quite
different than the traditional full-time
employee whether it's you know the
day-to-day but also the behavior
how would you categorize this persona if
you had to imagine the typical
freelancer that you're you know that
that is a potential user of payload what
what are what do they embody who what
what what are sort of their
characteristics that make them a good
person as a payload customer yeah sure
so
um
i i think the ideal
power customer or
you know what sort of embodies them as
it were
um is someone who perhaps is is starting
out wanting to take more control i think
sort of a large portion of people who
find paolo very useful are people who
have started freelancing out of the
pandemic so whether that was out of a
necessity for a diversification income
and and getting multiple jobs to create
a more stable income uh through to uh
whether they're part of this sort of
great resignation
and it's a continuation of the general
societal trend we saw even before covid
of people wanting to uh have a greater
control over their their work life and
um wanting to sort of have these
aspirational dreams of this is what i
want to do and being their own boss and
so on um and so i'd say you know palo
users are very aspirational um and often
have are fairly new to freelancing um
and uh
you know everything's slightly
overwhelming um and they just want to be
able to focus on the things like getting
your first client and making sure you're
charging the right amount and so on uh
versus
am i spending the right amount am i
putting the right the right amount aside
for taxes um like you know are there
things i can do throughout the year to
make sure my my tax situation isn't uh
ungodly at the end of the year
um
you know i i'd say uh they're
aspirational uh
relatively new freelancers um who
generally speaking provide services um
rather than sort of necessarily selling
goods
right so and i want to take you back for
a second to your history as a zoologist
you mentioned you started as a zoologist
and you know i i can imagine there's a
few different you know
a few different
skills that one would be able to
transition because essentially you know
you're you're studying you know
you know it's not herd mentality but
you're start your you're studying the
way that a new type of consumer is is
operating in the world and you're
essentially creating infrastructure for
this and i i don't know 100 what this
wall just does but
tell me just a little bit about you know
what what being zoologist isn't and i'd
love to make some parallels yeah sure so
so yeah for those who don't know yeah i
actually studied zoology at university
and i did a bunch of conservation
projects around the world once a bunch
of research and such um and
um yeah then fell
from there into tech startups i actually
got my first uh job as a first employee
in a tech startup um because i actually
applied for an unpaid photography
internship because i like photography at
the time went to their first ever their
first ever business meeting and i kind
of liked what they did and i wanted to
prove that i could do more than take
pretty pictures and so i actually
without permission admittedly so this
could have gone badly wrong i went out
and closed their first ever paying deal
with domino's and the ceo pulled me
aside and said well how did you do that
because
however you did it you're now doing it
permanently because we're going to hire
you um and so i've gotten to actually to
do their business development and close
about 40 deals for them and and the
company did fairly well um and that's
sort of what got me away from zoology
and into tech startups was an unpaid
photography internship role um
and yeah i guess you know i'd say the
parallels
are far more around like how a scientist
like between what i do now and how a
scientist
has to think
is we're a very data-driven company we
have hypotheses and we test those
hypotheses fairly rigorously um and then
we follow that data um and so i'd say
that the parallels are less between sort
of the market that i'm uh that that
we're working in and far more in the how
we work as a company um is is is quite
data-driven um and we you know
especially having three found uh three
co-founders you know we we all have a
decent amount of experience um and you
know what i find really really useful
actually is when we do have differing
opinions uh and then those uh allow us
to actually move in a much better
direction uh than if only one of us was
was uh you know a sole founder if that
makes sense so we create hypotheses test
them um and go from there and i'd say
that's the parallel between sort of my
past life and my now tech life
right and now if you're looking at
community as a as a driving force for
this gig economy and freelancers so
you're not just
a data platform and a tax platform and a
fintech platform
you're actually actively encouraging
you know people to try out freelancing
right i mean effectively you're yeah you
know there's a section
there's a section on the faq that says
can pelo help me get my first freelance
work and the answer is yes we actually
are are working on that so tell me a
little bit about
community as a mentality and how payload
is actually contributing to the driving
force sure of this so i i think you know
one thing that really stands at the
heart of palo is the reason it was
created was to make freelancing easier
to make sure that people could start it
and not feel overwhelmed
because like the three of us as
freelancers really really enjoyed that
period of our lives um and
think it shouldn't just be
that some succeed in it and others don't
um and really want to encourage more
people into freelancing um and help
people along along that journey um and
what we've tended to find is um you know
fellow freelancers and people who have
been there done before are the best
resource and so yes we we started the
community ourselves we actually have
about a hundred thousand people within
our online communities and we very much
encourage them to help one another with
advice
uh job opportunities collaboration
opportunities
um
and we try and sort of uh sort of drive
that community in certain directions so
if we see you know designers uh having
certain issues with a a particular
problem then we try and create a
discussion around that
um and i think it's just sort of really
important to help people especially
younger people um as well um who you
know really are starting out fresh and
perhaps they're starting freelancing
before they've even never had a w-2
gig
and so
yeah i guess helping people understand
how to price their services
um how to advertise themselves how to
find their first clients
um and so yeah we you know we do
in effect not through pillows core
products but through our community we do
help people find those jobs i think we
probably post about six jobs a day uh in
our own internal teams our communities
um and so you know we're definitely
there to advocate for people to to be
self-employed and take that their lives
into their own hands and take control
and
and be freelance
so is it easier for a person who
who's this is their first work who's
never had a w-2 to transition to
freelance or is it easier for somebody
who's been in the workforce for a while
and says you know what i actually want
to try this who who is who is it easier
to convince sure this is i would say the
easiest honestly are those without
children on a mortgage um the the people
who
the people who have you know a mortgage
children real solid outgoings um that
depend on their income i'd say the move
to being freelance is a much more it's
not that it's not plausible it's
definitely plausible it's just the
stakes are higher um you know when you
are younger when you have uh fewer uh
financial dependents uh on you
um the stakes are very low right if if
freelance doesn't work out and there are
some months which are really low and
some months which are fine um then it
doesn't matter as much
and so i'd say people who have a
mortgage have uh children and so on it
it's just the stakes are higher and
therefore they're more nervous about it
doesn't mean it's not possible doesn't
mean it's something it shouldn't do they
just inherently are more nervous about
taking it on and so what you tend to see
is you tend to find people having a
longer buffer period so what a lot of
freelancers do is start out they start
out in w-2 they start doing stuff on the
side the w-2 covers their main uh costs
and then eventually as they get more and
more experienced on their side gig
then the side gate becomes their real
gig and we've seen a lot of people uh do
that over the last couple months uh who
are palo users in fact who we speak to
uh who have
really sort of during this sort of last
couple months
been a part of that great resignation
and though they've done this side gig
for about a year year and a half they've
now decided this is the time to leap you
know they're getting a good enough
income from the side gig to then fully
commit to it
um and that's what we tend to find a lot
of people do and um those with mortgages
and children would just have a longer
buffer period right they
want to make sure that that
freelance income is a bit more stable
that there it's a more mature business
before they then make that uh full
transition
fantastic so if we're now looking at at
palo what is sort of the status of the
company and and what are the things that
are keeping it up at night so it's
really exciting i think um you know it's
it's
uh
i think being in a fast-growing company
the things that keep you up is how fast
you have to solve problems um i think
the the um
thing that keeps me up is usually a
problem has occurred at 8 pm and i now
need to solve it or generally the
company now needs to solve it before 8
am the next morning and as a fully
remote team and we do work across
different time zones often actually that
ends up being uh sometimes easier
because you know as you're going to
sleep someone who might be able to solve
the problem is is is just waking up
um and that's definitely a benefit i
think
of remote working we're definitely
advocates of remote working for sure
um
but i think
you know where we are at the company as
a company at the moment is we we sort of
did a a soft launch uh earlier this year
which is very exciting on product hand
got to number one products uh of the day
uh on on on launch day
um and then we've essentially just been
sort of uh developing and um perfecting
the product so we're very very uh
product focused as a company we truly
believe that if you create a great
product that people love
and are willing to pay for um that
that the rest sort of follows quite
naturally um and so we're just very very
focused at the moment on perfecting how
we solve people's problems and probably
will be for the you know the entire uh
company's uh life cycle um but that's
sort of where we are now and and growing
that community uh and sort of getting
people to understand what palo is as a
brand as well
um but yeah very very exciting year to
come
and if we're looking at
the way that
you know you're going to strategically
position yourself once you've sort of
hit the nail on the head and said okay
this is we found product market fit we
are providing the value that we want to
be providing and we believe that this is
a value that that if we continue
providing it at scale we'll make for a
meaningful company what happens then how
do you you know a little bit about the
the freelance economy you know in the
bigger picture how do you then grow from
a beta product to now scaling it so that
freelancers all over the world sure so i
think it's ultimately um about people
seeing
or thinking of palo uh when they think
of i want to solve
xyz problem i think that's where we sort
of position ourselves as saying okay
well if you if you are contemplating
freelancing if you are thinking of that
then palo is a tool in fact the only
tool you're going to need to make your
financial life uh going into freelancing
a lot easier um and then hopefully sort
of through our community as well you can
help you know we can help you get that
first job um help you get that advice uh
from our community whether you should be
incorporated as an s corp single member
llc multi-member llc whether you stay
sole proprietor whether you work
remotely what state you work in whether
it matters uh if you if you jump between
states as we found during cove a lot of
people were surprised that perhaps
hawaii and california were both asking
for state taxes because he spent too
much time in both states um you know so
uh
you know i think the the general
positioning for us is making sure that
people think of paulo
um whenever they um
think of freelancing and just sort of
positioning ourselves as a key tool uh
for freelancers
but what needs to happen in order for
them to make this leap from saying paulo
is you know yes it's it's an offering
versus okay if freelancing equals palo i
mean that is really the that is the
connection you want to make in in the
world right that is the connection you
want to make that it's such a fun
fundamental basic need by you by
freelancers and it's so trivial just
like if i wanted information i google it
so if i want to be a freelancer i need
to follow it what what how how do you
get to that point so i think
um you know for a part it's it's
knowledge uh sort of uh
leadership if that makes sense so
showing that i was a good resource um
for
uh for freelancers not only as a tool
but and in the community but also in
general like sort of helping people
understand that
you know we we know what we're talking
about in terms of freelancers like we're
a fully freelance um team right we're
with 43 individuals all of whom are
self-employed um and all of whom have
had a self-employed background um and so
you know as a company we really are
truly built for freelancers by
freelancers and and i think sort of over
time uh the positioning is is very much
to
to help people understand that we know
what we're talking about we aren't
coming from a corporate background where
we've noticed a hole in the market and
want to fill it we really do truly
understand the problem uh and have
experience in the space
um
and therefore can can provide help to
those individuals um
but yeah it's it i think sort of you
position yourself as a knowledge leader
um for a start um and and and over time
people start to
uh associate but i think you know one
thing with palo is it's so
easy to be able to
uh sign up that you know if we're not a
neobank we are not a bank as it were
you're not having to think about okay
well do i sell this new account and so
on you know we're we're a software layer
that lays on top of your banking so you
can you can bank with whoever you want
you can bank with uh you know wells
fargo and
capital one and have your amex card and
so on you can spend hard you want to uh
you can do all your business personal
stuff on one card or multiple cards
whatever you want to do and we'll set on
top of that and help you
um you know no matter who you bank with
and i think that's a key one for us is
there are many players in the market
where it's requiring you to set up a new
bank account which sometimes people see
is a bit of a barrier and as sort of
second thought whereas palo is something
you can easily try out and easily play
around with without thinking oh god i'm
setting up another bank account but if i
don't like it and i have to close it
down and then does that have an effect
on my credit score and well that's the
jazz
sure
henry uh it sounds like an awesome
journey and it sounds like you're you're
also
at a position where you know we're still
learning what the freelance world is all
about and
banks are learning and i can't and i
think it's pretty trivial to think and
to assume that you know in the coming
years there will be new financial
offerings whether it's banking offerings
and financing options and and i think
that being the the operating system for
the infrastructure for that there's a
lot of opportunity there so best of luck
with palo thank you very much for taking
the time to share with me it was very
enjoyable on my end and stay safe stay
healthy and best of luck
thank you michael thank you thank you